one of my favorite stories in the gulag  archipelago there's a man who's at a  Soviet labor camp and he's sentenced to  die but he wants to see his wife one  last time and so the prison guards tell  him that yeah we can send your wife to  come see you you can't tell her what's  about to happen because if you tell her  that then you know then maybe she ends  up getting shot too so he spends three  days with his wife just walking around  this prison camp and uh never tells her  what's about to happen to him he just  spends time with her and shoulders this  burden entirely on his own and then as  soon as she is sailing away on the ship  uh he's you know undressing to go before  the firing line you compare that to  today when a man comes home like in  tears what's wrong I stub my toe and  there's quite a contrast there I think